une production du studio SF
Miano sans filtre le podcast où on parle
de ce qu'on veut avec nos invités pH
Quentin avec moi dôme plante cette
semaine on fileuse en philosophe
cette semaine parce qu'on reçoit Clio
qui est une professeur de philosophie
université Montréal très triste du
centre de recherche en éthique une
recommandation qu'on a eu de ces
étudiants ou anciens étudiants qui nous
a dit que c'était le cours le plus
fascinant qui avait eu à l'université
donc on s'est dit il faut absolument lui
parler Rio a aussi fait des
interventions à la radio à la défaite
émission
puis moteur de recherche entre autres
est habitué de parler dans les médias
donc on se questionne puis assez
beaucoup à la philosophie l'éthique
internationale finalement
donc un exemple vous allez comprendre de
quoi les questions qu'on parle de ça
c'est un épisode quand même un petit peu
plus
un peu plus chargé en concept en donc
n'hésitez pas à faire pause à aller lire
sur différents auteurs que Rio avait
cité ou sur les différents concepts
pour être capable de suivre ce que
peut-être que c'est juste moi qui
était de la musique mais je pense que je
pense que ça vaut la peine pour voir
profiter au maximum la conversation il y
a beaucoup de stocks mais je pense que
si on fait l'effort intellectuel de
d'essayer de comprendre les concepts de
suivre je pense que c'est vraiment super
intéressant
sauf qu'ils sont vraiment enrichissants
aussi
on se questionne on pose des questions
c'est ça la philosophie dans le monde
c'est de poser des questions plus que
d'avoir des réponses puis c'est de
trouver les bonnes questions à se poser
ce qu'on fait tout au long du podcast
puis de semer la graine de la réflexion
qui peut être
[Musique]
chez vous
la suite de cette phrase bloquée ceux
qui nous écoutent là c'est quand même
niche qu'on fait là
pour l'anecdote là pour les gens qui
nous écoutent quand on était au à
l'école primaire à chaque fois qu'on
s'en allait pour aller à la cafétérin la
cafétéria la salle où est-ce qu'on
allait manger il y avait une genre de
plaque
c'est une plaque avec une citation c'est
dans Saint Roch le ceux qui est ceux qui
savent là à l'école Saint-Roch et sur le
bord de la rivière Saint-Charles il y a
une plaque il y avait une citation donc
là je vois juste la starter puis tu vas
essayer je la connais par coeur
depuis on n'a jamais parlé de ça on sait
jamais reparler depuis le primaire puis
on passait devant chaque jour on faisait
comme un petit mais on faisait comme si
on se recueillait devant prière
non plus depuis le second depuis le
primaire
on le fait
la graine de paix doit d'abord être
semée dans le corps spirituel afin de
naître au sein du cœur de la vie humaine
exact
[Musique]
on se pose les bonnes questions
aujourd'hui
podcasts
le podcast de cette semaine est présenté
par cosy oh je vous ai parlé déjà de mon
divan j'ai rêvé sur mon divan j'adore
mon divan mais là cosy vienne de sortir
des tables ok des tables ajustables donc
soit des tables de salon que vous mettez
devant votre divan ou des tables pour à
côté de votre divan pour déposer vos
verres etc de gérer de chevet c'est ce
qu'on dit c'est ça des tas de chevet
puis l'étable vous irez les voir là mais
ils sont incroyables parce que il
s'ajuste mettons les temps de cheval tu
peux les mettre à la hauteur que tu veux
ok les tables de salon
ils peuvent avoir l'air d'une table
normale
[Musique]
mais tu peux aussi lever un panneau qui
vient se rapprocher ton divan pour par
exemple mettons la top dessus travailler
sur du vent ok
matériaux différents je sais pas s'il y
a différents types de matériaux celle
que j'ai vu sont en bois c'est le cas en
fait je veux m'acheter son tambois mais
vite parfaitement avec tous les divans
de cosy qui sont faits pour ça c'est
incroyable puis aussi tu peux planifier
la forme de ton divan pour qu'il fait
vraiment ton salon mais là avec la table
elle vient s'ajuster parfaitement avec
de comme un espèce de salon ou de salon
de chambre où est-ce que tu veux mettre
ton disant peu importe super
ergonomique il y a aucun espace qui est
perdu c'est incroyable c'est que mon ami
paisi que les autres sorts du podcast a
un grand divan aussi elle a fait venir
chez eux qui fait un U mais tout au long
de ces murs
qui est un appartement dans le Québec et
quand même sommes plutôt assez petits en
l'air énorme grâce à
aller voir ça pour vrai cosy et leur
nouvelle table ordin c'est de la bombe
de A à Z cosy.ca puis merci d'encourager
le podcast mais honnêtement vous les
auditeurs allez voir ça parce que c'est
incroyable oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc ça roule c'est parti merci beaucoup
d'être là merci pH merci Dominique merci
merci d'avoir accepté l'invitation
comment commence par parler si de vous
étudiants qui
sont
fait ça tantôt aussi
qui nous ont recommandé puis le sujet me
paraissait vraiment intéressant
puis comme je voyais téléphonique à la
radio quand même souvent aussi
premièrement ça me flatte énormément je
savais pas que c'était certains de mes
anciens étudiants qui se trouvent avec
de vos abonnés qui avaient recommandé
mon nom ça sent pas tellement je sais
pas quoi mais vraiment c'est super
gentil j'ai toujours eu un rapport bon
je peux pas je peux pas présumer que
tous les étudiants ont aimé mes cours
mais moi je peux dire que j'ai mis tous
mes étudiants dans la mesure où c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui me nourrit
incroyablement cette relation là avec
les étudiants je pense pas qu'on devient
professeur d'université si s'il y a pas
quelque chose dans l'enseignement qui
nous tient mais peut-être qu'on peut
devenir professeur d'université si c'est
la recherche qui est vraiment le motive
ce qui est aussi mon cœur mais je pense
que dans mon cas c'est d'abord il y a
avant tout l'enseignement qui est qui
est vraiment médecin et me nourrit même
dans mes recherches et puis la chronique
les chroniques radio c'est un peu la
même chose aussi dans la mesure où c'est
la vulgarisation scientifique et
d'ailleurs merci pour l'invitation moi
j'ai écouté certains de vos de vos
émissions de podcast puis c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment ça que vous faites en
fait la vulgarisation scientifique pour
le grand public éduqué mais sans être
spécialisé en tout cas un grand public
intéressé par ces questions là et puis
les chroniques radio c'est arrivé un
petit peu par hasard aussi j'ai commencé
en 2017 à l'époque c'était les
éclaireurs avec Patrick maspurian avant
qui deviennent le moling Man et puis on
avait invité c'était juste une et par la
suite c'est devenu plutôt une invitation
à une collaboration mensuelle pour moi
au moins c'est le rythme qui me convient
le mieux c'est assez court pour être là
souvent mais assez long pour laisser une
bonne préparation exactement c'est un
peu c'est un tout à fait puis ensuite tu
devenu moteur de recherche avec Mathieu
Dugas j'adore parce que c'est beaucoup
en fait des professeurs d'université ou
des professeurs de cégep qui
interviennent là et puis aussi la
défunte émission puis on lit plus on lit
de fou et on lit que j'aimais beaucoup
aussi alors c'était pour ce genre
d'émission et ce qui m'emballe c'est
justement l'exercice et je sais pas si
je vais réussir en ce moment mais c'est
vraiment l'idée de pouvoir rendre des
questions difficiles plus accessibles
pour que tout le monde puisse avoir
un point de vue un peu plus éclairé sur
sur ces débats
comme ça entre on en parle souvent ici
puis c'est un petit peu la mission qu'on
s'est donné quand on a fait un genre un
redressement éditorial du sans filtre
podcast pendant au fil des années où
est-ce qu'on s'est dit qu'on a vu un peu
l'opportunité de faire là on a un
humblement une assez large tribune puis
c'est le fun de pouvoir recevoir des
gens qui sont un peu dans l'ordre tour
de recherche de science puis que là de
faire le pont jusqu'à
les gens qui qui sont monsieur madame
tout le monde qui qui ont peuvent
bénéficier de cette connaissance là mais
qui ont juste pas accepté j'ai vu un de
vos derniers épisodes je pense qu'il
parlait de l'Iran puis avoir une
couverture approfondie sur
par des spécialistes sur un sujet qui
quand même interpelle tout le monde
c'est vraiment en tout cas c'est
vraiment formidable je pense que le
comédien l'humoriste a dit était passif
je ne m'acheter des billets pour son
choix
en tout cas un peu timide
donc toi tu as la discipline de
recherche c'est l'éthique mettons pour
les gens qui connaissent pas du tout la
philosophie c'est quoi le titre ouais
alors les tiques c'est une branche les
philosophie qui est aussi vieille que la
philosophie comme telle donc pilon va
parler vraiment de façon je m'en excuse
avant c'est de façon très limitée de
l'histoire de la philosophie occidentale
c'est très curieux parce que je suis
asiatique et dans mon département c'est
une collègue italienne qui est
spécialiste philosophie chinoise et moi
la personne d'origine coréenne japonaise
je suis je me suis spécialisée en
philosophie politique anglaise peut-être
aussi parce que peut-être que dans mes
propres biographies c'était une façon de
mieux connaître ce monde qui
m'accueillait et essayer de mieux
comprendre
en quoi consistait les l'histoire de
cette culture occidentale mais toujours
est-il que donc
de la philosophie
occidentale et de l'histoire des idées
on remonte à l'Antiquité grecque et je
sais Dominique que tu as justement
étudier certains cours avec
un tout petit peu et ça fait très
longtemps on pourrait aussi Aristote de
mémoire
qui est un professeur absolument
magistral à l'Université Laval en fait
qui fait carrière là-bas et qui est donc
que tu as été initiale et philosophie
ancienne et donc
du coup c'est vrai qu'avec Aristote
éthique à nicomac par exemple donc
chez Harrison chez Platon chez Socrate
la question de alors qu'est-ce que c'est
l'éthique alors l'éthique c'est
qu'est-ce que c'est des questions
philosophiques qui vont avoir
un lien avec des questions de valeur on
peut poser seul de 1001 façons on peut
on peut se poser la question est-ce que
c'est bien ou c'est mal et souvent ça va
donner lieu à de la philosophie morale
comme tel on peut se poser les questions
de qu'est-ce que la vie bonne et ça
c'est plutôt une question éthique au
sens un peu plus large on peut se poser
la question aussi des fondements
éthiques de la justice et c'est la
raison pour laquelle la philosophie
politique et l'éthique sont aussi
parfois très très
arrimés l'une à l'autre alors ce que je
fais c'est de la philosophie politique
appliquée à toutes sortes d'enjeux
éthiques
qui soulève des questions de est-ce que
c'est bien ce que c'est mal est-ce que
c'est de bonnes choses à faire alors
ouais mais quand on dit est-ce que c'est
bien c'est mal c'est pas l'idée de c'est
vraiment pas l'idée de dire à tout le
monde faites pas ça faites ci ou de
rédiger un code de conduire ou un code
de valeur c'est vraiment pas ça l'idée
c'est tout simplement de au moins savoir
comment poser la bonne question et là
par exemple je fais référence à de vous
inviter Martin Gibert qui était qui est
aussi un ami collègue du centre de
recherche en éthique dont je suis la
cause directrice comme j'expliquais tout
à l'heure en coulisse mais donc Martin
Gibert c'est un spécialiste en éthique
d'un intelligence artificielle alors
encore une fois l'idée c'est pas
tellement de se demander qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire qu'est-ce qu'il faut pas
faire avec les robots c'est plutôt de
savoir comment poser les bonnes
questions pour aller identifier les les
problèmes qui nous guettent etc alors
c'est sûr que en bout de ligne on a
développé un argumentaire au sujet d'un
problème ça peut être éthique
environnemental c'est peut-être éthique
de la guerre juste ça peut être éthique
des inégalités de santé
éventuellement il y a quand même
l'espoir de contribuer une proposition
une solution ou au moins une comment
dire une voix d'action alors
éventuellement il y a un aspect
prescriptif c'est à dire
étant donné les arguments étant donné à
façon qu'on a déchiffrer la question on
pense que peut-être on devrait faire si
cela ceci mais je vous avouerai que ni
dans le contexte ce podcast c'est ni
dans le contexte de mes cours
l'objectif de dire qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire c'est pas vraiment l'objectif qui
m'allume c'est vraiment plutôt invité
les étudiants ou inviter les auditeurs à
réfléchir par eux-mêmes mais avec des
outils
théoriques c'est le propre de la
contribution philosophique dans ce genre
de question ou de débats ordinaire c'est
de proposer des notions théoriques qui
peuvent peut-être nous aider justement y
voir un peu plus clair mais c'est une
nation théorique là j'imagine que
comme tu mentionnais quand le veuille ou
non
dirige vers une façon de d'aborder
certains enjeux c'est ça c'est si on
pose les bonnes questions souvent ça
trace un peu la ligne directrice
exactement puis c'est pas ça que entre
philosophe autour des mêmes questions il
va avoir 1000 et une réponse il y a déjà
eu un étudiant c'est vraiment
intéressant la façon qui avait posé ça
fait pas très longtemps alors si tu
disais écouté le podcast mais ça
reconnait
est-ce que c'est ça devient pas un peu
contradictoire quand on présente la
prétention de la philosophie comme
pouvant contribuer au débat et la quête
de la philosophie qui tend quand même
vers une sorte de réponse
universalisable ou qui s'approche de la
vérité puis finalement dans les débats
de philosophe il y a toujours un qui dit
Oui puis l'autre qui dit non etc alors
dans un certain sens c'est vrai que le
propre de la philosophie et de la
réflexion philosophique et de chercher
des réponses qui ne sont pas du même
ordre que des réponses mathématiques par
exemple ou donc on réfléchit souvent
avec des comment dire en fait souvent il
faut pratiquer une forme de
modestie intellectuel je pense même si
chacun on prétend avoir un peu plus
raison en vertu de la cohérence de notre
argumentation des qualités de notre
argumentation
on prétend quand même s'élever un tout
petit peu au-delà de la pure opinion
parce que justement le travail la
philosophie c'est de travailler les
arguments rationnels la cohérence
logique etc mais ça veut pas
nécessairement dire que on va trouver
une réponse absolue une vérité qui
dépasse l'histoire ou les contextes
sociaux pas du tout alors il y a
plusieurs approches en tout cas
philosophiques sur justement
est-ce que le contexte historique nous
limite dans la façon de voir les choses
est-ce que le contexte culturel nous
limite ou est-ce que à travers la
diversité culturelle il y a moyen quand
même de trouver un consensus au sujet de
certaines intuitions qui sont un peu
plus universalisables mais en fait même
toute la question de qu'est-ce que c'est
l'universalité et qu'est-ce que c'est
l'universalisable en philosophie en ce
moment soulève un paquet de questions
parce qu'on veut pas non plus tomber
dans une forme de scepticisme
decepticisme c'est la position selon
laquelle il y a rien de vrai et donc
très rapidement ça devient du
relativisme tout azimut
donc si rien n'est vrai parce que c'est
justement pas des preuves scientifiques
en philosophie qu'on peut qu'on peut
mobiliser alors ce que chaque tout le
monde a raison exactement et c'est sûr
que quelqu'un qui est en philosophie en
éthique travail le plus souvent avec je
pense l'idée ou bien de justifier le
scepticisme et le réactivisme de façon
rigoureuse ou bien le plus souvent pour
dire non non il y a sûrement quelque
chose au-delà
de la pure pignon
subjective à quoi on aspire grâce à la
rationalité et grâce à cette
argumentation rigoureuse qui ne fait pas
appel à la religion
on peut être philosophe et religieux
mais la démarche philosophique ne fera
pas appel à des sources transcendantales
comme des croyances religieuses et en
même temps on peut pas nécessairement
faire appel non plus à l'expérimentation
scientifique c'est que c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui se situe entre les
deux je dirais la beauté des questions
philosophiques
et de l'existence humaine c'est que
quand on se pose la question c'est quoi
le sens de la vie
d'expérimentation il y a pas de former
le mathématiques qui vont me donner
exactement qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire
qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire face aux
inégalités abyssales en relation
internationale
quelle est notre obligation en tant que
génération face aux générations futures
qui vont subir vraiment les effets
catastrophiques du changement climatique
c'est des questions qui bien sûr
reposent aussi sur une certaine
connaissance scientifique ça c'est clair
il y a beaucoup de philosophes
d'ailleurs je fais partie un peu de ce
de cette génération de philosophe
politique appliqués où on essaie de plus
en plus vraiment d'être à l'écoute l'un
des données factuels empiriques etc pour
cerner la question éthique mais la
question de quelle est notre
responsabilité morale
envers les pays on va de développement
ou envers les femmes qui sont sous le
poids de la persécution ailleurs
qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand on voit un
pays être envahi par un autre et qu'on
est des
est-ce qu'on a le droit d'intervenir ce
sont toutes des questions qui sont
proprement philosophiques parce que là
c'est vraiment plus des questions de
justice fondamentale qui doivent guider
nos positions
est-ce que il y a est-ce que
une objectivité dans l'éthique est-ce
qu'on a réussi à la trouver où justement
tout dépend du contexte social puis de
l'époque puis alors il y a plusieurs
approches par rapport à cette question
là mais encore une fois la question est
philosophique alors ça c'est le premier
point de départ la question
philosophique dont parlons-en donc on
fait de la philo ensuite il y a
plusieurs approches parce que donc au
travers des sages en histoire des idées
des philosophes se sont saisis de cette
question et l'en formulé en fonction de
pas en fonction de leurs paramètres
culturel etc il y a des philosophes qui
prétendent que oui l'objectivité existe
en philosophie parce que la rationalité
existe et donc supposons qu'on suivrait
ce film là parce que c'est qu'un filon
quand même assez comment dire canonique
dans l'histoire des idées depuis Platon
de Pierre Aristote Platon
Aristote
Platon en particulier c'était quelqu'un
qui de toute évidence croyant à
l'objectivité de certaines idées
platoniciennes il invoquait le ciel des
idées pour justement désigner une sphère
de réflexion qui était pure et qui
pouvait donc être purement rationnel
purement objectivable purement
universalisable et donc d'idées justice
idée de vrai etc quand au 18e siècle on
fait un immense saut dans l'histoire
mais quand en philosophie morale c'est
un philosophe allemand qui va croire que
en effet il existe des lois morales il
va appeler ça des impératifs
catégoriques les impératifs catégoriques
pourquoi parce que tout simplement
lui disait vous savez quand on est face
à un dilemme moral peu importe lequel il
soit est-ce que
c'est tout aussi vrai aujourd'hui pour
une personne tibétaine que ce l'était
pour un Britannique du 19e siècle que ce
livre pour des Québécois du 21e siècle 2
+ 2 est égal 4 dans n'importe quelle
langue
peu importe le contexte historique peu
importe le contexte culturel etc et donc
quand croyait que les vérités murales
étaient exactement du même ordre
autrement dit peut-être un exemple très
très facile infligé de la souffrance à
une innocent un enfant
infligé de la cruauté complètement
gratuite
et une objectivement mal
exactement donc parlant on peut statuer
qu'il y a une certaine forme
d'objectivité mais après ça j'imagine
que les situations sont de plus en plus
complexes
ce n'était pas très intéressant
d'ailleurs qui a été présentement
culpabilisé par certaines philosophes
féministes pour penser pour penser la
solidarité transculturelle de tous les
combats féministes mais en étant
respectueux des contextes culturels dans
les cas dans lesquels ces combats se
poursuivent donc par exemple puis là on
va glisser un peu sur un terrain
controversé mais
glissons
parce que justement il y a un article
qui est un article très intéressant qui
qui circule en ce moment dans le nouvel
épisode observateur mais qui donc
s'appuie aussi sur toute une littérature
et philosophie féministe
anglo-américaine notamment
sur ces questions là pour ne pas citer
ce week-end qui avait écrit qui vient
d'écrire un livre là-dessus alors on
peut sans contradiction
dire que le Presson des femmes est
toujours une mauvaise chose
et la pression des femmes dans certains
contextes et dans un contexte absolument
criant et aigu en ce moment
forcer des femmes apportées des signes
religieux et à les contraindre à obéir
un code de conduite qu'il est qu'il est
comment dire qu'il est subordonne qui
les assujettissent etc
c'est quelque chose qui qu'on ne doit
pas encourager
au nom de l'émancipation des femmes et
ceci dans ce contexte est un exemple de
lutte féministe auquel il faut souscrire
et auquel il faut sympathiser solidarité
solitaire et ce n'est pas du tout
contradictoire de soutenir que dans
d'autres contextes de demander aux
femmes de les obliger à sacrifier leur
appartenance leur identité religieuse
est aussi une forme de discrimination
dans la mesure où on ne respecte pas
leur libre choix et encore une fois donc
dans certains contextes le combat
féministe peut
en venir on a soutenir des femmes qui
veulent revendiquer leur identité
culturelle leur identité religieuse dans
tel contexte surtout lorsqu'elles sont
en minorité dans une société où les
comment dire le code de conduite de la
majorité les amèneraient à se départir
et à se sacrifier d'une partie
constitutive de leur
identité tant il est aussi longtemps
évidemment que cette identité choisie
par elle et pour elle-même alors c'est
ça l'idée c'est et donc voyez c'est un
exemple un peu controversé
en tout cas c'est un exemple
très actuel éminemment actuel qui qui
dit que oui il est possible d'avoir
justement une certaine idée de ce qui
est universalisable donc on
dit non à la pression des femmes mais
ensuite
les milieux sociaux culturels exactement
c'est ça et donc ouais
cet exemple est intéressant c'est
intéressant aussi d'arriver avec la
la réalisation que c'est pas
contradictoire nécessairement alors que
techniquement ce qui est revendiqué
c'est quasiment l'inverse
oui tout à fait non c'est pour ça que il
y a eu un certain mouvement féministe et
pas juste les féministes a eu donc
d'autres approches en philosophie
notamment en relation internationale
puis vous savez tout le mouvement sur la
décolonisation en ce moment là qui
traverse toutes les disciplines et qui
effectivement
transforme aussi certaines questions et
certaines débats en philosophie
politique surtout dans mon domaine en
éthique des relations internationales ou
tout à coup il y a des voix des voix
philosophiques qui n'ont jamais été
entendus parce que ces voix
philosophiques qui viennent de certains
pays qui ont été colonisés étaient
considérés justement comme des voies
subalternes des voix inférieure des voix
moins articulées moins intelligentes et
pourtant et pourtant on parle de ces
voix exprimées par des individus sur qui
on impose aussi on a imposé la
colonisation et avec la colonisation on
a imposé aussi des codes de conduite une
certaine conception de ce qui est bien
de ce de l'égalité des familles des
hommes tels que ça doit être absolument
interprété on a on a justifié des formes
de pression colonialistes par des par
exemple chez certains philosophes on a
entendu parler vraiment de comment il y
a eu des justifications de défériorité
raciale de certaines communautés de
certaines populations et une des vertus
civilisatrices du colonialisme
consistait justement à les ouvrir à la
voix de la rationalité
exactement et donc au nom de la raison
universelle au nom du bien universel
autrement dit on venait leur dire vous
ne le savez pas vous-même mais nous
venons vous coloniser pour votre propre
bien civilisationnel alors ça peut
évidemment donc en tout cas il y a même
sur ces questions là encore une fois des
débats philosophiques dans le sens on
s'en sort jamais parce que un des un des
uns un des travaux comment dire une des
tâches des philosophes c'est aussi de
creuser autant que faire ce peu la
profondeur de ces questions là mais il y
en a demain pas moins que on est arrivé
aussi un moment où en philosophie on a
développé un concept qui s'appelle par
exemple la justice épicémique et
qu'est-ce que c'est que l'injustice
épicémique épistémique ça veut dire
quelque chose qui a rapport au monde de
la connaissance et quand on parle des
injustices dans le monde de la
connaissance on désigne ce phénomène
c'est quand les rapports de force dans
le monde social vont se répercuter dans
le monde Savoie et par conséquent
pendant des millénaires les femmes
n'avaient pas accès à des positions
d'autorité estimée dans les universités
parce que justement l'université qui
était enseigné par des hommes on
enseignait aussi que les femmes étaient
naturellement inférieures à tel point
qu'elle n'avait pas le droit de vote à
tel point qu'il y avait pas le droit
d'indépendance économique etc et dans le
même ordre
comment dire pour qu'une telle
oppression colonialiste puisse sévir
pendant
des siècles il a fallu que ça soit
soutenu quand même par des valeurs
culturelles et par des doctrines
philosophiques aussi qui consistait
essentiellement à dire oui oui c'est
correct on fait bien de faire ça parce
que nous au nom de la raison
scientifique ou de la région universelle
on sait ce qui est de mieux pour tous et
si on allaitons avec l'Empire qui
civilisait le monde et les barbares
de justement de la philosophie puis de
l'éthique de se dire mais on a réfléchit
à ces questions-là
d'un point de vue philosophique
rationnel donc on s'est élevé comme on
disait un peu plus tôt au-dessus de la
simple pignon donc on estime que notre
réflexion et une valeur ajoutée tu sais
donc j'ai plus raison que quelqu'un qui
aurait pas réfléchi à ce toi mais le
sujet de t'imposer à toi sur ma
réflexion
ben le ça devient plus éthique de
vouloir imposer une question qui rejoint
justement l'intervention que à laquelle
je faisais mention tout à l'heure c'est
que justement en cette période de
décoloniser tout là et notamment la
philosophie on est dans une période de
grande introspection critique et
la première chose qu'il faut dire c'est
encore une fois je pense que on apprend
de façon un peu brutale mais on apprend
vraiment la nécessité de la modestie
intellectuelle c'est vraiment vraiment
important plus que jamais qu'on regarde
sur les réseaux sociaux qu'on regarde
qu'est-ce qui va arriver avec Twitter
l'impact des réseaux sociaux par exemple
pendant la pandémie ou pendant dans la
montée des papillons mais aussi en ce
moment là avec au lendemain parce que là
on se parle enfin je sais pas si on peut
le dire mais on se parle au lendemain
donc de l'élection de villa au Brésil on
se parle au lendemain de Elon Musk qui
prend twitter etc alors il y a plusieurs
interprétations du monde passé mais en
ce moment il y a des gens qui se
réjouissent de ce qui se passe en
Amérique centrale en Amérique du Sud
parce qu'on a l'impression quand même
que des régimes autoritaires qui sont en
train de
de tomber et puis qui ont été remis en
question puis c'est peut-être un peu à
cause des réseaux sociaux etc des forums
publics de discussion mais en même temps
on sait aussi que les grands
comment on appelle ça le consortiable de
gogo
on sait à quel point l'incidence des
Gafa peut être très dangereuse pour les
démocraties contemporaines puis bon on
regarde twitter etc mais tout ça pour
dire que dans tout ce contexte là alors
les philosophie doit pratiquer une forme
de modestie intellectuelle dans le sens
qu'on doit nous-mêmes être prêt à
réviser notre propre histoire puis nous
propres erreurs pourquoi on persiste
ensuite quand même à vouloir défendre
les philosophie puis le rôle
progressiste de la philosophie on
devient philosophique philosophe aussi
parce que il y a des grandes pages de
lumière dans l'histoire de la
philosophie ou grâce à cette réflexion
critique capable de se déconstruire
capable de se regarder
capable d'être dur avec elle-même on a
été aussi capable d'avancer beaucoup
alors je parlais tout à l'heure de
comment il y a eu des degré philosophie
qui ont vraiment piétiné la nature des
femmes
et il y a eu aussi de grandes percées
philosophiques qui ont donc soutenu et
justifiés l'égalité des femmes
et
donc il y a ça la même chose aussi avec
la philosophie de l'arabe donc il y a eu
des grands moments d'obscurité dans
l'histoire de la philosophie qui est
vraiment fait fausse route en pensant en
pensant mal l'égalité des hommes vous
savez
liberté
[Applaudissements]
fraternité
et voyons ces libertés égalité
fraternité ça c'était le trio
autant du contrat social autant du
XVIIIe siècle
liberté égalité pour qui c'est ça pour
la fraternité puis on a peut-être perdu
de vue la sororité au 18e siècle a fallu
quelqu'un comme Olympe
qui donc a écrit une déclaration des
citoyens de la République et pendant un
certain temps il y a eu un mouvement
égal carré c'est contractualiste qui a
soutenu justement
cette Persée féministe par exemple un
peu plus ou moins en même temps un peu
plus tard
britannique grâce à une influence
décisive de Highway
sa belle-fille donc une immense
influence sur sa philosophie a été
quelqu'un qui a proposé au Parlement
britannique un projet de loi pour
reconnaître le droit de vote des femmes
puis ensuite il y a eu les femmes
elles-mêmes qui ont pu parler de leur
propre voix et signé de leur propre
plume des textes pour reconnaître
l'émancipation des femmes et en même
temps
en même temps il y a eu aussi donc des
thèses en philosophie qui
soutenait l'inégalité des races entre
les hommes alors pour parler de
l'égalité mais pour qui etc et en même
temps il y a eu des philosophes comme
transmise qui écrit de weshow contrat en
référence notamment à une féministe car
Pitman qui avait écrit de sexe et dans
les deux cas c'était pour critiquer
comment et contrat social pu complément
oublié les femmes et comme un contrat
social a pu complètement oublier
l'égalité des esclaves
sur sur qui on avait construit la
démocratie américaine par exemple alors
donc c'est l'histoire de la philosophie
l'histoire des idées est une histoire
complexe il y a des pages sombres et de
grands moments de révélation ou des
grands moments d'épiphanie des grands
moments de progrès social et je pense
que pour tous ceux et celles qui
persistent ici ont philosophie et qui
persiste des signes aussi au sein des
universités et et je dirais même
peut-être même pour des gens comme vous
qui fait comment dire qui fait de la
passerelle on est recherché
universitaires et la place publique on
continuerait pas à faire ce travail-là
si on croyait pas que grâce aux idées on
peut aussi changer les choses pour le
mieux qu'on peut réconcilier cette
histoire-là qui est trop parfois ah oui
d'autant plus que en tout cas ça dépend
peut-être des points de vue mais
on peut être très hibis c'est une autre
position philosophie qui consiste à
reconnaître l'imperfection fondamentale
des êtres humains et leur grande
tendance à faillir à faire des échecs à
commettre des fautes donc je pense que
c'est une des conceptions peut-être des
plus lucides d'ailleurs de la nature
humaine que de reconnaître notre
faillibilité et en philosophie une fois
qu'on a reconnu ça est-ce que ça nous
empêche de
faire de la philosophie quelqu'un comme
parce qu'il y a quand même moyen d'être
cohérent avec nous-mêmes et donc il y a
des positions cohérentes qui sont
nécessairement dire ah ça y est on va
attendre la véritable absolue au même
titre qu'une vérité scientifique on peut
atteindre quand même des vérités qui
sont trop loin cohérentes il serait
incohérent de ne pas soutenir par
exemple à la lumière de toutes les
connaissances historiques
biologiques empiriques que l'on a que
l'esclavageisme aujourd'hui est
absolument un mal moral qu'on ne peut
plus
et qu'on n'aurait jamais dû en fait
justifier mais aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui
soutiendrait l'esclavagisme au même
titre que aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui
soutiendrait le racisme ou les
inégalités raciales
et cette proposition un statut de vérité
parce qu'elle est cohérente est-ce que
tu es un en science avec la méthode
scientifique on
la sentirafine toujours et puis on
découvre toujours un petit peu plus loin
de
notre champ de connaissance puis là il y
a quelqu'un qui prend qui prend flambeau
puis qui l'amène un petit peu plus loin
tu sais puis grâce aux expériences grâce
aux données de ça
je n'ai pas l'impression qu'on peut
reculer c'est une fois qu'on a découvert
quelque chose une fois qu'on est une
fois qu'on a mesuré le boson de X dans
le mesurer on peut pas le démesuré
est-ce qu'un est-ce qu'un philosophie
on la trajectoire est
et sur une droite aussi comme ça est-ce
qu'on est-ce qu'on avance toujours ou
même ou bien c'est relatif puis on était
on pourrait aussi à une certaine époque
rentrer
philosophiquement que certaines théories
qui sont de à nos yeux injuste
aujourd'hui deviennent est-ce que
absolument et justement
je pense qu'il y a une Un certain regard
critique sur l'histoire des idées en ce
moment qui dit que l'histoire de la
philosophie n'est pas si lumière que ça
même pas l'histoire des sciences
d'ailleurs parce que cette espèce de
moment d'introspection critique dans
toutes les disciplines y compris
l'histoire des sciences qui elles aussi
a été traversée parce que j'appelais
tout à l'heure des injusticiers
épistémiques et qui ont eu un impact par
exemple l'histoire d'amitié sur le corps
des femmes on se rend compte à quel
point ça a été un peu n'importe quoi
bon et puis donc c'est pas comme si
l'histoire est je sais pas si vous avez
entendu parler de temps mescoon
qui a beaucoup parlé des révolutions
scientifiques et comment ça arrive dans
l'histoire des sciences des changements
de paradigme et on pourrait penser que
c'est purement linéaire puis qu'on s'en
veut toujours vraiment en ligne droite
vers le progrès or il se trouve que
c'est pas si linéaire que ça c'est pas
aussi propre que ça c'est souvent par
essai erreur il y a souvent aussi tout
simplement des il y a vraiment des
facteurs sociaux sociologiques qui vont
déterminer pourquoi hop tout à coup
c'est cette c'est cette théorie qui va
gagner la faveur du public ou de la
communauté scientifique ou détriment
qu'une autre mais il y a pas réellement
une nécessité absolument scientifique
pour poursuivre cette voie plutôt qu'une
autre et c'est un peu la même chose
aussi dans l'histoire de la philosophie
alors on peut penser que on peut se
raconter aussi une histoire qui a l'air
linéaire puis peut-être qu'elle est
linéaire en effet dans la mesure où un
moment donné il y a une erreur qui était
commission c'est tous on a tous
mais il y a des salir tout en fait ou
comment dire
l'apparente linéarité de l'histoire de
la philosophie n'est pas nécessairement
dû pour des raisons de vérité ou de
rigueur scientifique c'est aussi parce
que un moment donné il y a eu des
facteurs sociaux des emprises
biologiques des erreurs etc qui font en
sorte que on a suivi cette voie là comme
je vous dis le fait que des gens n'ont
pas eu droit de parole dans cette
histoire des idées ou dans cette
histoire des sciences autrement aussi
affecter le cours des choses et ça il y
a pas de doute là-dessus alors qu'est-ce
que ça aurait été si depuis tout temps
tout le monde avait pu véritablement
jouir de l'égalité politique et
épistémique qu'est-ce que serait donnée
etc alors il y a des gens qui quand même
quand je parlais de ok même si on est
faillibliste ça veut pas nécessairement
dire qu'on est sceptique
veut dire qu'on croit plus à rien ou
qu'on est relativiste ça veut dire que
ok Goose ce qui revient à peu près on
croit plus à rien mais si on y fait
ébiliste on peut quand même croire une
forme de cohérence
on peut croire au progrès des idées en
tout cas on peut ne pas désespérer alors
on peut être optimiste pareil même face
au changement climatique il y a des
philosophes qui sont en train de
soutenir comment dire
la validité de l'espoir puis de
l'optimisme
climatique d'un point de vue
philosophique parce que c'est quelque
chose qui est mesurable qui de l'ordre
des sciences aussi mais c'est quoi le
drôle de travail de philosophe par
rapport à la question comme ça comme du
changement climatique alors excellente
question une question d'autant plus elle
est tellement tellement
urgentes alors le point de vue aussi de
comprendre comment est-ce que on peut
philoopher de façon positive ou de façon
optimiste par rapport à ça je crois que
c'est le genre de question qui va
résonner beaucoup avec les gens qui nous
écoutent
tout à fait c'était d'ailleurs un sujet
de chronique pour une émission de radio
amateur de recherche c'était la mère
d'une adoles de deux adolescents qui
poussaient cette question là parce que
qu'est-ce qu'on transmet à nos jeunes et
puis très très drôle en tout cas encore
une fois un bel hasard parce que je
pense que c'était le 26 octobre il y
avait un article de fond là qui était
paru dans The New Times où on parlait
justement
comment dire de comment on peut quand
même garder espoir
face à même politiquement là face à tout
ça alors qu'est-ce que c'est que
la question de justice climatique en
philosophie par exemple dans le domaine
de l'éthique des relations
internationales éventuellement il y a eu
des splits aussi il y a eu l'éthique
environnementale etc et justice
climatique est presque comme devenu un
domaine en soi pour souhaiter tellement
il y a des travaux qui sont nourris par
l'urgence la situation et la
contribution des philosophes est
vraiment très intéressant de la première
contribution quand même notable que
j'aimerais citer c'est Stephen cardiner
qui avait parlé de de Perfect moral
Storm et ça ça fait déjà plusieurs des
signes de ça qui avait écrit cet article
et il décrivait justement notre inertie
notre apathie notre paralysie politique
face justement l'urgence des changements
climatiques qui s'en viennent qui sont
absolument de son point de vue et je
pense que là il y a un consensus sur le
monde universel que c'est vraiment
scientifiquement
et ça c'est vraiment vrai là que ça s'en
vient oui c'est s'envole l'avancée puis
ça va être un autre point de controverse
on veut une troller en tout cas donc je
pense que ces gens-là ils nous écoutent
c'est que donc alors ce philosophe il
disait pourquoi c'est de Perfect moral
pourquoi c'est la trompette morale
parfaite c'est parce que c'est à la
croisée de deux choses dans le domaine
de l'éthique des relations
internationales on voit tout le problème
éthique de la non coopération et
pourquoi c'est un problème éthique parce
que cette coopération cette absence de
coopération autour de Kyoto autour de
Paris autour de etc les traités de Paris
etc tout vous savez que Stephen Harper
c'est voulait sortir Kyoto les trucs de
Paris avec les Américains c'était pas
etc donc
cette défection
cette non coopération est souvent mue en
fait par une forme d'égoïsme qui peut se
chiffrer notamment par la pâte du gain
économique alors donc souvent
parce que c'est pas rentable sur le
planctoral parce que c'est pas rentable
sur le plan économique etc on va avoir
tendance à
ne pas aller dans le sens de ce qu'il
faudrait faire pour vraiment mitiger les
les catastrophes climatiques parce que
ça sert pas de nous intérêts immédiat
donc il y a une première catastrophe au
niveau des relations 45 qui comme au
niveau vertical horizontal pardon et un
autre axe vertical et celui-ci serait un
axe temporel et là c'est les théories de
justice intergénérationnelle notre
génération manque de coopération avec
les générations futures
oui parce que nous sommes mis par nos
propres intérêts égoïstes il faut savoir
c'est quelque chose quand même il faut
vraiment prendre le coup de Sein si on
est vraiment sérieux nous notamment les
québécois canadiens qui sont les plus
privilégiés les plus privilégiés de ce
monde si on prenait au sérieux
l'engagement pour mitigé au maximum les
catastrophes climatiques du futur ça
nous coûterait en terme de qualité de
vie beaucoup plus qu'il n'y comprend le
pense et serions-nous prêts à sacrifier
notre confort énergétique nous
automobile etc tout ce que vous savez
bon alors donc notre génération est
prise aussi d'une forme d'égoïsme moral
au détriment donc des générations
futures auxquelles s'ajoute le problème
philosophique suivant les générations
futures n'existent pas encore et donc
quelle est leur statut moral face à nous
comme on peut pas avoir de contrat
social avec eux à la limite on peut
avoir une sorte de contrat social à
l'échelle internationale tout le monde
traiter mais avec une réserve mentale
secrète que quand ça va pas faire mon
intérêt je vais faire d'effections mais
avec les générations futures le problème
philosophique il est souvent c'est qu'on
est même pas prêt en fait l'argument
pour convaincre les générations
actuelles de sacrifier pour les
générations futures est encore plus
grand alors c'est pourquoi Steven
gardener d'une parfaite tempête morale
de ce point de vue là mais donc
c'est intéressant de penser à un futur
comme des des voix qui existent pas
encore en fait est-ce que est-ce que
c'est vous là
c'est quoi leur peau en fait à ces voilà
ces personnes là qui qui existent pas
encore c'est qui
qui ont pas de voix puis est-ce que
est-ce qu'on se trompe de parler pour
eux ou est-ce qu'on doit parler pour eux
c'est des questions en tout cas je
dirais que le consensus des philosophes
et c'est là où vous pouvez peut-être
mesurer par vous-même si c'est utile ou
non au départ mais moi je pense que
c'est utile un gros consensus chez les
philosophes qui travaillent sur
l'urgence climatique c'est de dire les
générations futures comptes et on a le
devoir en tant que génération
contemporaine de rendre compte de leurs
intérêts dans nos négociations
contemporaine autour des traités
climatiques etc et donc ça c'est puis il
faut quand même de l'inventivité
conceptuelle pour faire valoir pourquoi
ces gens qui n'existent pas encore
on est en main statut moral actuel et ça
c'est justement le genre de contribution
dans la compréhension
entrepostale c'est comme le grand
extinction causée par l'homme de ce que
j'avais donc je vais pas parler au nom
des scientifiques qui ont d'abord
développé cette définition là mais oui
c'est à peu près ça mais j'entreposène
l'air de l'anthropocène qui comme vous
le décrivez à cette et ce moment où
l'empreinte géologique des êtres humains
vont avoir éventuellement quand même une
empreinte catastrophique étant donné ce
qu'on est en train de voir en ce moment
correspond aussi sur le plan
philosophique avec une forme
d'anthropocentrisme ou d'un point de vue
moral tout est centré sur les intérêts
des êtres humains et donc les intérêts
des animaux les intérêts aussi des êtres
humains futurs et de la planète future
tout cela est évacué de notre radar
alors en tout cas tout ça pour dire que
je pense que c'est une contribution
vraiment fascinante de la part des
philosophe un autre sujet qui est
intéressant et ça ça reste à débattes je
pense il y a des philosophes aussi qui
s'intéressent beaucoup au débat actuel
ok les générations futures comptes mais
alors il y a des il y a des philosophes
qui vont réfléchir sur est-ce que
comment dire est-ce qu'on devrait
privilégier les intérêts des plus
démunis d'aujourd'hui les plus pauvres
d'aujourd'hui et donc jusqu'à sortir un
point justifier une forme de croissance
économique pour que ces pays envoient de
développement puissent également
pour que ça puisse bénéficier au plus
pauvre des plus pauvres mais sachant que
ça va aussi comment dire détériorer
l'environnement des plus démunis dans le
futur montant alors c'est aussi c'est
vraiment fascinant en fait c'est des
calculs qui a tellement de données qui
sont impossibles à calculer finalement
parce que je comprends l'argument de
dire ici en originor on a profité d'une
force d'industrialisation on a polluer
que à l'infini puis là maintenant on
voudrait instaurer certaines règles pour
limiter la progression de d'autres pays
qui pourraient profiter un guillemets
économiquement de ces mêmes
technologies-là mais en polluant puis
aujourd'hui on se dit il faut il faut
limiter mais
oui mais c'est super intéressant ce que
vous dites parce que il y a deux choses
c'est d'abord il y avait le rapport
Stern qui est un rapport donc très
important dans la littérature sur
l'environnement et c'était un rapport
qui était qui avait été rédigé par un
ensemble de scientifiques et puis de
économie etc et qui tenait compte
vraiment pour la fin comment dire il y
avait vraiment une véritable intégration
des travaux des philosophes et c'est
pour vous dire encore une fois à quel
point les travaux des philosophes
surtout qu'on fait de la philosophie
politique appliquait des problématiques
contemporaines je pense pas que c'est
futile je pense je plaider pour ma paroi
je pense vraiment qu'on peut quand même
contribuer au débat et donc les intérêts
des générations futures etc commencer à
faire partie quand même des questions là
qui sont en train de de la façon qu'on
pose la question sur les changements
climatiques et ça je pense que c'est
vraiment quelque chose qu'il faut
souligner ensuite ce qui est intéressant
de ce que vous avez dit c'est que par
exemple le traité de Kyoto encore une
fois dans la littérature sur
l'environnement le trading que tout
était quand même
ne serait-ce que d'un point de vue
purement intellectuel parce qu'il y
avait la liste des pays a puis la liste
des PIB puis il y avait des comment dire
un traitement différencier par exemple
les pays les plus industrialisés
devaient respecter tel quota puis on
avait admis notamment pour la Chine et
pour l'Inde et puis considérés en voie
de développement des quotas plus
généreux pour ne pas enfreindre leur
droit au développement économique etc
etc en bout de ligne qu'est-ce que ça
donne comme résultat empirique vous avez
raison de dire que c'est difficile de
chiffrer et c'est pour ça que la
conception des philosophes n'est pas
nécessairement au niveau des chiffres ou
des faits ça va être plus au niveau de
c'est quoi l'argument derrière est-ce
que c'est exactement
ce qui est plein de Pilates ça nous
amène sur un terrain
il peut avoir des questions
philosophiques sur à peu près tout là
mais par exemple la croissance
économique est-ce que il y a vraiment il
y a des théories là je sais libérales la
puissance méchant libéral au sens
vraiment noble du libéralisme c'est
toute une tradition qui a mis vraiment
l'enfant sur les libertés individuelles
toutes nos démocraties contemporaines
sont issues en partie de cette tradition
libérale mais libéralisme vient aussi
avec une forme de libéralisme économique
liberté économique aussi ça veut pas ça
veut pas dire que tous les libéraux sont
des ultra capitalistes mais c'est vrai
que beaucoup de libéraux sont en faveur
d'une théorie de la croissance
économique puis l'idée c'est que la
croissance a des externalités positives
un peu comme la théorie du ruissellement
quand une société s'enrichit sa
bénéficie au bien-être de tout le monde
notamment au plus des avantagés pour
apprendre par exemple les tests célèbres
de John Ross
une société qui comprend bien les
principes de justice va faire en sorte
que elle va permettre des inégalités
socio-économiques grâce à la croissance
économique parce que ça va mener tout le
monde vers le haut et en particulier ça
va pouvoir mettre en place des principes
de justicetributive par exemple des
mécanismes de fiscalité de taxation qui
va faire en sorte que on va tous
collectivement se mettre d'accord pour
financer un régime public de santé qui
va bénéficier finalement et améliorer la
qualité de vie du plus déjà avantagé de
la société qui va avoir accès à ça et
donc ça c'est une théorie formidable
alors il y a des gens qui vont dire la
croissance économique même si ça a un
coût environnemental c'est important etc
mais nous sommes aussi à l'heure où
ces questions-là deviennent un peu
secondaires on dirait avec
l'urgence d'urgence
avec le climat on dirait que tout le
reste
si un impondérable qui rentre dans
l'équation de chacune de ces questions
là il semble que Canon qui devient plus
importante à mettre de l'avant
même avant demeure une question à se
poser c'est à se poser sauf que
j'imagine que il doit avoir un certain
consensus au sens où il faut prioriser
certaines questions puis d'autres
questions qu'on pourra se pencher une
fois qu'on aura réglé un problème
pressant mais là il y a carrément il y a
toute une génération de philosophes
aussi qui commence à être vraiment de
plus en plus égalitariste aussi parce
que
bon est-ce que c'est est-ce que c'est
envisageable est-ce que c'est de
l'utopie ou est-ce que ce qu'on pensait
de l'utopie
il y a 200 ans puis que s'avère vrai
aujourd'hui bon etc mais l'idée c'est
que une jeune génération de philosophes
politiques commencent à remettre en
cause aussi la croissance vous savez les
théories de décroissance etc on essaie
de remettre à l'or du jour quelque chose
qui va décarboniser l'économie qui va
démocratiser les sociétés et qui va par
exemple donc
à remettre en cause vraiment le
capitalisme l'échelle mondiale et donc
parce que cette cette ce discours
philosophique consiste à dire
ça va pas le capitalisme contemporain le
capitalisme d'un point de vue
philosophique repose sur l'exploitation
des êtres humains sur l'exploitation de
la des ressources le capitalisme
va de pair avec l'extraction des
ressources qu'elles sont humaines qui
sont naturelles et ça va nous péter en
pleine face
regarder la pandémie moi je travaille
plutôt sur les inégalités de santé à
l'échelle internationale mais regardez
comment la course prédatrice au vaccin a
mis en relief les inégalités abyssales
qui existaient déjà avant la pandémie
alors ce sont les plus riches pays qui
ont pu mettre la main sur les vaccins on
était rendu à la il y avait des pays
pauvres qui avaient même pas réussi
encore à mettre à donner la première
dose et là dans ce contexte là il va
avoir des mutations qui nous reviennent
etc etc tout ça parce que les droits de
propriété intellectuelle sur les brevets
pharmaceutiques il y a une coalition de
à peu près une centaine de pays soutenu
par un Médecin sans Frontières etc qui
avait demandé à l'Organisation mondiale
du commerce
de suspendre des brevets pharmaceutiques
au moment de la course au vaccin contre
le strass cover 2 contre la covid-19 et
les pays les plus riches l'Union
européenne le Canada l'Australie les
États-Unis on a tous dit non
et donc dans ce contexte là
et puis en tout cas tout ça pour dire
encore une fois le capitalisme à
l'échelle mondiale ça va de pair avec un
régime de droit de propriété
intellectuelle sur les brevets
pharmaceutiques qui bénéficient au plus
riches d'entre nous dans notamment des
compagnies pharmaceutiques et les États
qui les hébergent et qui ont sa profit
en fait tout ça pour dire que
ces questions philosophique là j'ai
l'impression qu'ils se rendent
pas tout le temps jusqu'au preneur de
décision c'est parce que
si c'était le cas si on vivait sur dans
un monde où un monde dirigé par un
groupe de philosophes qui s'assoit
autour d'une table qui discute comme la
meilleure ça serait quoi la meilleure
direction pour
la planète dans son ensemble
ça serait pas on prend pas les mêmes
décisions
ce que vous dites parce que
c'est figure aussi la figure du
philosophe roi qui existe depuis Platon
juste Platon préconisé était pas
tellement faveur de la démocratie si je
me trompe pas ah oui non ça c'est une
raison c'est à dire qu'il y a un mythe
qu'il faut déboulonner c'est que oui
dans l'Antiquité grecque il y a des
embryons de la démocratie mais c'est pas
c'est pas pratique que ça parce que par
exemple à l'époque d'Aristote
l'esclavagisme était complètement
justifié par un en tout cas mais tout ça
de dire si on si on avait un groupe de
philosophes qui prenaient qui discutait
ensemble éthiquement pour prendre toutes
les meilleures décisions possible dans
l'intérêt de du plus grand nombre de
personnes possibles on sait ce serait
incroyable mais en même temps ça serait
une dictature
la figure du philosophe roi ou du
législateur éclairé chez Jean-Jacques
Rousseau enfin ce sont les figures qui
ont parce que la question était posée
est-ce que ça serait pas bon etc mais en
bout de ligne c'est peut-être une très
bonne raison d'avoir une très bonne idée
d'avoir une sorte de division des
pouvoirs pas seulement législatif
exécutif et judiciaire pour empêcher
comment dire le Monopoly tyran mais
aussi
très aussi longtemps qu'on qu'on laisse
aux intellectuels la liberté académique
la liberté d'expression et à l'ensemble
des citoyens quand ils sont en tant que
le débat a lieu sur la place publique
étant aussi longtemps qu'il y a quand
même des passerelles en ce que par
exemple les chercheurs en philosophie ou
dans d'autres disciplines on va dire de
pertinence sur tel débat tant ils sont
tant que ces choses sont mises en place
c'est peut-être une très bonne idée en
fait que
on soit pas au pouvoir pour Pâques qui
ait des conflits d'intérêt pour pas
qu'il y ait vous savez c'est peut-être
une bonne chose que la réflexion se
fasse de façon purement désintéressée
par rapport aux avantages
des reins pouvoir mais là la question
qu'on se pose aujourd'hui c'est est-ce
que est-ce que est-ce que les conditions
sont réunies et je vous pose la question
à vous
[Musique]
les médias les médias d'information les
réseaux sociaux
les systèmes de publication des articles
scientifiques et le coût que ça
représente pour les citoyens
le manque de langue commune
tout ça je sais pas entre le langage des
chercheur et le langage des politicien
pour convaincre les électeurs je sais
pas
est-ce que des médias
répondent à l'idée du contre-pouvoir là
maintenant on tombe quasiment plus du
côté de podcasts quasiment là pour avoir
quelque chose comme une alternative
critique moi à mon avis le problème en
ce moment c'est que les conditions sont
pas optimales
tout à l'heure on parlait de l'idée de
s'élever au-dessus de l'opinion mais
j'ai l'impression que c'est vraiment
pas
répandu parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'en ce moment c'est on est à l'air de
l'opinion le whisky a pas de réflexion
qui se fait au-delà de l'opinion tu sais
on a juste je vais prendre un exemple
vraiment
quand mais où on entend le Premier
ministre qui parle du troisième lien par
exemple à Québec qui dit moi je pense
que c'est une bonne idée c'est moi je
pense que c'est une bonne idée c'est
basé sur rien à part son opinion que
c'est une bonne idée selon lui le sait
alors que plein de monde partout qui
réfléchissent à cette idée-là qui
réfléchit au concept que des études
faites qui qui disent que non ou qui
disent que oui pour xxx raisons qui ou
ce qui se propose pas mais le discours
c'est moi je pense que c'est une bonne
idée puis tu vas voir après ça sur
justement les réseaux sociaux il y a
personne qui prend la peine d'écrire une
dissertation
sur sur le questionnement derrière le
troisième lien c'est oui ou non c'est
puis c'est c'est seul qui prend on
dirait en ce moment c'est le problème
justement c'est le problème je sais pas
comment quoi répondre à ça
le diagnostic du problème puis donc la
tâche par exemple des philosophes ça va
essayer de
comment dire de approfondir et de
détailler ce diagnostic là pour essayer
de réfléchir mais vous savez quand même
juste pour répondre à cette question là
il y a par exemple en philosophie il y a
des gens qui ont réfléchi sur les
pistocratie alors on parlait tout à
l'heure des injustices épicémiques mais
les pistocratie c'est les tests selon
lesquels les experts devraient être au
pouvoir donc c'est pas la démocratie
c'est pas l'aristocratie c'est
l'épistocratie mais ça soulève toutes
sortes de problèmes aussi
on pourrait aboutir à des comment dire à
des espèces de d'État purement
fonctionnaires qui en fonction de leur
expertise économique expertise
scientifiques etc manquerait d'une
vision plus holistique et d'une
conception de du bien collectif ou de
bien aussi exactement c'est ça pour
prendre direction il faut quand même
savoir si on va à gauche ou à droite
ou encore je pense que la tâche est
philosophe c'est de réfléchir quelle est
la notion de bien commun qui pourrait
nous unir
et les philosophes ont écrit 1000
dissertation là-dessus le problème c'est
que je sais pas si ça perdole pas
jusqu'à la place publique parce que des
fois souvent aussi c'est des idées qui
émanent de la place publique et les
philosophes essayent de de particulier
de façon plus rigoureuse mais il y a
comme pas de je sais pas c'est ça qui
qui me cause beaucoup de problèmes en ce
moment parce que la démocratie aussi
énormément de vertu je vais faire la
démocratie c'est mais la démocratie
c'est ça aussi qui met en place parfois
des gouvernements qui ont sabré les
fondements la démocratie
comme comme on ne vue récemment dans aux
États-Unis ou Brésil plein d'endroit
mais justement
comment que c'est tantôt on faisait un
peu la
liste ou les critiques de la du
capitalisme dans lequel on vit en ce
moment tu sais
[Musique]
j'ai quand même l'impression que
je me trompe que c'est quand même le
système dans lequel on a vécu les
humains dans lequel qui a peut-être le
moins de souffrance ou d'injustices ou
même si on était toujours des raffiner
ça puis il y a d'autres systèmes qu'on a
essayé puis que peut-être que sur papier
ou en théorie ou en pensez fonctionner
puis que dans les faits on s'est rendu
compte que c'était impossible à
appliquer parce que des mettons par
exemple une égalité totale ben ça
demande un contrôle total des
populations puis justement je demandais
c'est quoi finalement
est-ce qu'un consensus chez les
scientifiques de jeunes de jeunes
philosophes plus égalitarisme mais
est-ce que dans le concret
comment qu'on atteint cette espèce de
système là qui qui n'aurait pas de
souffrance de justice ce qui se passe
encore une fois je crois aux vertus de
l'optimisme quand il y a aussi longtemps
qu'il devient pas un optimisme nié
c'est-à-dire du déni qui est
justifierait une forme de Status Quo ou
de
amorphy ou d'inertie ou d'apathie mais
de l'optimisme judicieux qui nous aide
quand même à penser vers demain et cette
jeune génération puis c'est déjà une
idée moins jeunes mais
alors eux une des idées très en vogue
tout à l'heure quand je disais de
démocratiser des carbonisés etc c'était
le slogan de philosophe féministe et
d'économie qui se féministe mais c'est
pas juste des féministe ça c'est plein
plein de philosophes qui pensent que
une un peu comme connaissez le prix le
papa le prix Nobel dans le corps mais je
veux dire le grand économiste français
là ok Thomas qui est ici c'est un grand
économiste français qui a
réussi à se faire inviter dans des
talk-shauts alors il y a réussi quand
même un excellent travail de
vulgarisation si jamais vous pouvez
mettre la main sur Thomas
et puis lui ce qui propose c'est un cap
sur les richesses un moment donné il y a
un moment où il y a un seuil de richesse
on peut pas dépasser ce seuil de
richesse
après un certain exactement et puis il
va avoir des philosophes qui vont dire
écoutez il y a plein de comment dire
il y a plein d'arguments
philosophiques fondées sur la le respect
de la dignité des droits humains
fondamentaux de l'égalité etc et de
l'efficacité même
et des externalités positives
système plus égalitaire peut-être pas
communiste ça je comprends ce que vous
voulez dire et c'est la raison pour
laquelle la tradition de la démocratie
libérale demeure une tradition quand
même très riche parce que tout à l'heure
je disais bien que les libéraux au sens
noble du terme c'est pas des
c'est pas des alarmes en tout cas il y
en a de certains de ces philosophes que
Marvel nous dit qu'il était mais pas
tous ne l'était pas c'était quelqu'un
qui défendait l'étape-providence ou la
justice la sociale démocratie mais
ces philosophes là ce qui vont dire
c'est que
à partir de ce qu'on connaît de la
démocratie libérale
ce serait des ajustements au fond pas si
révolutionnaires que ça que de demander
par exemple des seuils sur la richesse
que de demander une plus grande
redistribution des richesses collectives
que de demander
là où ça n'existe pas un régime public
de santé
qui inclurait par exemple des soins
dentaires un régime public d'éducation
etc
des mécanismes qui réduiraient les
ingrédients et il y a aussi toute une
génération de laquelle je fais partie
qui travaille dans le domaine de
l'éthique des relations internationales
pour dire sensiblement la même chose
mais cette fois-ci entre les pays à
l'échelle internationale c'est sûr que
c'est différent parce que c'est pas
demain la veille un gouvernement mondial
et peut-être qu'on veut pas de
gouvernement mondial mais il faut quand
même trouver des mécanismes de
coopération internationale par rapport
aux enjeux climatiques par rapport aux
enjeux de santé par rapport aux enjeux
économiques parce que en bout de ligne
et ça c'est un argument toujours un peu
politique qui est pas purement
philosophique mais l'idée c'est de dire
écoutez si on fait pas si on change pas
de
route là on s'en va droit vers le mur ça
va nous rattraper en termes de crise
sanitaire parce que encore une fois vous
savez quelque part la covid-19
cette préfigure tous les zones c'est à
dire toutes les maladies qui vont être
contracter aussi à cause de cette
proximité
non naturelle entre les êtres humains et
les animaux parce qu'on a tellement
dénaturé l'environnement naturel des
animaux cette promiscuité ça va ça va
nous revenir en pleine face avec des
virus qui vont muter qui vont nous
dessiner etc le changement climatique on
le voit déjà malheureusement
des canicules meurtrières des
inondations etc ça va nous péter en
pleine figure les ingallka abyssales
donne lieu même un conservateur vous
pourriez faire valoir cet argument là
ça donne lieu à des migrations
économiques
catastrophiques à l'échelle
internationale
donc vous les pays riches ne voulaient
pas à vos portes mais que le qu'on le
veuille ou non ça va venir à vos portes
et il y a un problème éthique de ne pas
secourir des réfugiés qui sont en train
de se noyer dans la Méditerranée sous
vos yeux il y a un coût éthique grave
probablement fondamental mais il y a
aussi un coût de ressources combien de
temps pensez-vous survivre dans ce monde
devenu de plus en plus interdépendant en
investissant toutes vos ressources pour
la protection de vos frontières
quand alors
les gens de la droite
[Musique]
vous savez
coûter plus cher à vos libertés
individuelles
de s'imaginer que au-delà de nos
frontières c'est pas notre problème
[Musique]
[Rires]
je sais pas combien de temps qu'il me
reste mais c'est aussi c'est une
question tellement tellement
fondamentale ce que vous avez soulevé
comme question à l'échelle global mais
peut-être pour faire
je sais pas moi peut-être ce dernier
truc ce dernier
un philosophe que vous connaissez
peut-être qui s'appelle Peter Singer
parce que c'est ça parce qu'il est aussi
à l'origine de tout le monde exactement
les droits des animaux mais il est aussi
connu pour avoir soutenu toutes sortes
de positions extrêmement radicales
et très controversé mais lui aussi c'est
un philosophe il faut quand même le
reconnaître qui arrive à se faire
inviter à des talk-show c'est pas que
c'est la gloire de se faire inviter à
des trucs mais ce que je veux dire puis
des fois c'est pas peut-être pas une une
idée non plus mais ce philosophe comment
dire sont de toute évidence lui ce qu'il
anime c'est cette
la vulgarisation et essayer de
convaincre tout le monde que les
frontières nationales ne devraient pas
avoir d'importance morale face au
problème de la pauvreté alors ça c'est
quand même c'était un pitch c'était un
argument qui le rendu célèbre à travers
un article
bon et et là ce qui est vraiment très
intéressant parce qu'il y a 1000 façons
de prendre ce problème là d'abord
quand on dit que les frontières
nationales n'ont pas de pertinence
morale ce qu'on veut dire par là c'est
que franchement par exemple l'espérance
de vie qui mesure les ingrédients à
travers les pays il fut à l'époque au
début des années 2000 quand il y avait
le VIH Sida en Afrique subsaharienne qui
faisait rage heureusement
on a réussi en 20 ans quand même à
contenir un peu simple c'est comme il
faut le dire des fois des fois il y a
des grands
moitié succès qu'il faut célébrer bon
mais à cette époque là l'espérance de
vie de quelqu'un
dans certains pays les plus ravagés de
37 ans tandis que au Canada j'étais dans
les 80 ans quel est le mérite moral
individuel que nous avons nous trois
d'être né par hasard par la simple
loterie naturelle je présume qu'on est
tous les trois ni ici au Canada puis
parfois on a droit à cette abondance de
ressources hydrauliques à cette
abondance de ressources politiques à
cette espérance de vie et quelqu'un par
le simple fruit du hasard et dépourvu de
beaucoup de choses mais c'est pas juste
hasard les frontières nationales et les
inégalités c'est aussi le fruit
d'injustice historique terrible et donc
non seulement ça devrait pas avoir de
pertinence morale
entre être humain celui-ci cette si on
avait une tarte puis autour de cette
table il y avait des gens de tous les
coins du monde qui étaient réunis je
suis convaincu qu'on ne se partagerait
pas les pointes de tartre en fonction de
notre nationalité alors pourquoi on le
ferait à l'échelle internationale
d'autant plus que certaines de nous
frontières
et de notre passé historique est
absolument injuste et donc on a
peut-être aussi été construit sur les
inégalités en partie en partie au moins
c'est sûr et donc il y a ça alors c'est
quelqu'un qui veut dire par exemple que
nous avons l'obligation vraiment de nous
départir du maximum de nos ressources
presque tant et aussi longtemps qu'ils
nous en coûte pas autant
en termes de sacrifice de news intérêts
fondamentaux c'est que ça c'est radical
la première version de son article
c'était vraiment qui est pas de bonnes
raisons pour que nous en tant que
citoyen québécois canadien pendant
période des fêtes
qu'on ne donne pas à des organismes
caritatifs de confiance
autant d'argent jusqu'à ce qu'ils nous
en coûte autant
en termes de sacrifice de nos propres
besoins fondamentaux pour se nourrir à
se loger se vêtir etc au fond en quoi
est-ce que je suis justifiée en quoi
est-on nous être sommes-nous tous
justifier de nous acheter une extra
paire de jeans plutôt que de contribuer
à la construction d'une école primaire
ou d'une clinique primaire de santé qui
va sauver effectivement des centaines de
vie de personnes qu'on va jamais côtoyer
moi alors il y a cette première
interrogation qui est absolument
troublante puis c'est vrai que je puis
je suis un certain point qu'est-ce qu'on
peut répondre à ça mais en même temps
il y a d'autres philosophes qui ont
contesté qui ont émis tout son objection
qui sont vraiment intéressants il y en a
une ça peut paraître très bien mais
c'est pas si trivial que ça sous une loi
qui disait le problème qui s'arrêtement
là c'est que ça appelle un tel héroïsme
moral que ça devient contre-productif
c'est à dire que chacun de nous à titre
individuel on porte le sort du monde sur
nos épaules mais ça devient tellement
lourd puis on s'est tellement qu'on est
faillible
finalement on va lâcher prise parce que
de toute façon je suis à louer de toute
façon
j'ai pas je vais pas le faire etc et
puis ça justifie presque mon
indifférence alors ça c'est quelque
chose dont il faut un backlash quand il
faut faire vraiment très attention
désolé pour les anglices et il y a un
autre euh
j'ai l'impression que tu sais faut aussi
prendre en considération dans les
calculs
nature humaine aussi l'été dans le sens
que est-ce que c'est réaliste de penser
que
tous les individus en tant qu'individu
vont s'élever au niveau moral éthique au
point de de leur propre chef donné de
leur argent sans il y a aucune autorité
qui les contraintes vers ça apparaît
ça fait partie absolument des objections
qui ont été adressées à Peter Singer
notamment le fait que comme il s'adresse
à des individus puis c'est vraiment aux
individus qui s'adressent il y a comme
pas de projets politiques parce que
c'est est-ce que c'est pas un problème
d'action collective qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait pas quand même mobiliser les
populations pour convaincre leur
gouvernement de faire quelque chose etc
et puis tu as 5 heures ne dis pas que
c'est pas vrai mais dit bonne chance et
en attendant que vous avez convaincre
votre population puis le gouvernement de
faire quelque chose
ça ne vous dispense pas de faire ce que
je vous dis de faire alors ça c'est
vraiment très intéressant un autre
argument que qu'on pouvait sentir un
petit peu dans votre objection dans ton
objection c'était est-ce que que c'est
pas contre nature de
traiter tout le monde sur le même pied
d'égalité en faisant fille de certains
attachements particuliers donc par
exemple c'est normal est-ce que c'est
pas normal quand même que
[Musique]
j'ai l'intérêt de mon garçon plus à cœur
que
le garçon du même âge
c'est terrible de dire ça mais je veux
dire franchement
ton cercle de famille tu es pas tes amis
vont avoir probablement plus importantes
en termes d'obligations morales que que
envers moi et je t'en voudrais pas et
c'est le phénomène qu'on appelle le
phénomène de la parcelle Témara elle
fait la même psychologique mais aussi
d'un point de vue philosophique alors
est-ce que c'est pas aussi justifiant
par exemple quand on regarde le film
Titanic je sais pas si vous avez déjà vu
le film Titanic
quand quand le tsunami le Titanic fait
naufrage à Leonardo DiCaprio qui est
dans l'eau glacée il voit la tête de lit
en chaîne qui flotte sur l'eau il a
grippe puis là il y a comme trois quatre
personnes puis là il y a Kate Winslet
cache tout le monde pour aller chercher
qui va l'accuser d'avoir un parti pris
au contraire on pleurait
[Musique]
donc ça c'est comment dire alors quand
l'élargit sur une échelle collective on
va se dire est-ce que le fait que les
Québécois décident ensemble de financer
l'Hôpital Sainte-Justine pour prendre
soin de nos petits est-ce que on est
moralement coupable de faire ça et de ne
pas en même temps
on aurait pu envoyer cet argent là puis
sérieusement il aurait pu sauver plus
d'enfants ailleurs dans le monde qui
sait
alors le problème de la parcelle
timorale est à mon avis un problème
vraiment vraiment intéressant parce que
dans le domaine de lycée des relations
internationales même si le point de
départ c'est de dire égalité pour tous à
l'échelle internationale après il faut
quand même réfléchir sur waouh qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire la personnalité morale
c'est quoi le sens
et c'est ça alors encore une fois il y a
maintenant des jeunes philosophes
politiques essaient de concilier les
limites justifiables
les limit justifiable du parti pris en
verre nos compatriotes
et les limites
non justifiable de l'exclusion d'autrui
alors on a de plus en plus des
philosophes politiques en relation
internationale qui essaient vraiment de
combiner les deux et que c'est vraiment
de d'essayer de penser
ouais mais c'est difficile
comme question
je voulais qu'on termine moi évidemment
je suis vegan je voulais qu'on termine
en parlant de tikenimal parce que je me
rappelle plus je pourrais pas citer
qu'il y a de ça mais qui parlait
d'unicien qui
peut convenir que le véganisme c'est la
chose à faire peut sans être lui-même
vegan recommandé le véganisme comme
étant la chose à faire puis je lisais
dans le courriel que toi tu n'étais pas
vegan tu n'étais pas végétarienne mais
que tu
vises de venir éventuellement c'est quoi
la position
éthique de dire je reconnais que c'est
la façon de vivre éthiquement sa vie
mais je ne l'applique pas à ma vie à moi
non c'est une très bonne question et
puis
je cite pas mes collègues pour me
dédouaner mais je me suis parce que
évidemment ces collègues là qui sont
effectivement de grands grands
philosophe euh
vegan qui sont au cœur justement de
toute la mobilisation intellectuelle et
je dirais même qu'il y a une expertise
québécoise je sais pas si vous seriez
d'accord mais en tout cas d'un point de
vue philosophique là il y a vraiment une
expertise philosophique québécoise qui
est vraiment de réputation
internationale et on parlait de piteux
singer et justement bah ce sont des gens
qui collaborent parfois parce que Peter
ce qui disait lui c'est juste pour
revenir là-dessus c'est que il disait
autant autant
ok lui il condamné les spécisme les
spécisme c'est de donner un parti pris
pour notre espèce humaine au détriment
des autres espèces vivantes sont
capables de ressentir du bien-être ou de
la souffrance au même titre que le
sexisme est une forme de parti pris qui
est moralement injustifiable basé sur le
sexe au même titre que le racisme est
une forme de discrimination moralement
justifiée à baser sur la race au même
titre que le nationalisme seront plutôt
Singer est une forme de parti pris
moralement
arbitraire fondée sur des frontières
nationales contingents au même titre les
spécisme doit être condamné parce que
c'est une forme de parti pris un
justifiable envers notre espèce humaine
alors donc tout ça pour dire que ce que
je disais à mes collègues c'est que ça
serait intéressant de me livrer en
peinture ou en fin de vraiment comment
dire confesser ma possibilités parce que
je pense ne pas être la seule être dans
cette dans cette espèce de masse de gens
qui sont très attentifs à ces discours
nouveaux moi c'est pas quelque chose que
dans les c'est pas c'est pas des essieux
dans lesquels j'ai baigné toute ma vie
c'est relativement récent c'est en
côtoyant justement ses amis ses
collègues que au fur et à mesure il
convaincre mais je sais pas si et puis
là au fond c'est comme si j'essaie de
convaincre des gens qui comme moi alors
ma prescription n'est pas nécessairement
de dire à tout le monde vous devriez
être végan
c'était plutôt ma position est plutôt la
suivante la déclaration des 400 500
intellectuelles qui ont condamné
l'exploitation animale je l'ai signé au
27 que beaucoup beaucoup de collègues
qui ne sont pas nécessairement végan non
signés parce qu'on sait que
nous avons maintenant les moyens
technologiques et les ressources pour
éviter je pense donc cette exploitation
animale industrielle alors par rapport
au fait de l'alimentation
je suis pas en ce moment c'est encore
une question que je me pose
mais je confesse aussi ma naïveté je
suis pas convaincue que nous ne sommes
pas les êtres humains des des animaux
comme tant d'autres et comme ma position
sur la prédation animale est pas
tranchée par exemple tu sais peut-être
qu'il y a des philosophes véganes qui
pensent que on devrait aussi autant que
faire ce peu
limiter la prédation entre les animaux
puis il y a des philosophes véganes qui
disent ben non non on va on va pas
moraliser ou condamner ce type de
comportement dans la nature alors
je suis pas convaincu que les êtres
humains sont nés pour être omnivores
sont nés par herbivore etc je pense que
je sais pas je suis un peu agnostique
mais autrement dit ma conviction n'est
pas que les
êtres humains
ne doivent jamais ou n'aurait jamais dû
consommer de la viande animale puis je
suis même sans Seb à certains contextes
culturels ou peut-être que bon mais je
pense que nous avons toutes les
ressources technologiques pour
éventuellement ne plus en manger et dans
cette veine là en ce moment la seule
raison qui fait en sorte que je suis
végétarienne quand je suis toute seule
quand je me nourris toute seule mais pas
nécessairement végétarienne et encore
moins Vigan en famille parce que nous on
a fait l'erreur de offrir l'option
végétarienne à notre enfant ou l'option
Vigan qui a été petit et je pense que ça
doit venir de lui-même alors je sais
très bien ce que je veux dire c'est que
les parents aujourd'hui qui sont
beaucoup plus avertis de cette
question-là que je ne l'était pas qui
décide de nourrir leur enfant vigun je
pense que ils ont totalement le droit au
même titre que
je considère que c'était peut-être une
erreur de notre part de ne pas avoir
offert cette option mais comme on a un
enfant c'est de prendre des décisions
pour lui du moins dans les premières
années de sa vie exactement que ce soit
c'est que un parent qui décide de le
nourrir Vigan bah pourquoi pas dans la
mesure où moi je
lisez de nourrir ton enfant Vigan au
moment où est-ce qu'il est
puis décidé de le nourrir vegan des
années plus tard quelle est la
différence parce qu'au final la décision
est prise
il n'est pas
il n'est pas seulement convaincu
peut-être par ce que encore une fois
j'ai peut-être pas les bons arguments
pour le convaincre je sais pas trop mais
il veut pas donc ça je crois quand même
à son libre choix puis je pense aussi
que quand sa nourriture son alimentation
ne dépendra plus de notre cuisine
puis que il pourra venir manger avec moi
de façon végane ou de façon végétarienne
à sa vie je pense que c'est une
conversation plus intéressant pour moi
qu'on aura à ce moment-là
alors puis ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui va être complètement
c'est pas un titre de philosophe que je
dis ça c'est complètement pas loin de
tirer mais
il court risque alimentaire un risque
parce que je pense aussi que
éventuellement se nourrir la viande va
comporter des risques plus grands que de
ne pas se nourrir la viande
c'est quoi un risque alimentaire et
qu'il court aussi un risque éthique
d'avoir tort quelque part
c'est vraiment bizarre mais le poterfly
pour moi c'est quand il va être adulte
il va pouvoir se nourrir par lui-même
puis moi je vais devenir végétarien mais
pour vous dire la vérité j'étais en
train de commencer à penser que ça
commence à je peux commencer à le
devenir
mais
je sais pas si qu'est-ce que tu réponds
toi à ce genre d'argumentation là très
bancal ouais moi je trouve que oui je
trouve que l'évidence est assez clair
plus je te parle même pas au point de
vue de la santé je peux même que
proprement que l'on pourrait même
ajouter l'aspect environnemental dans
dans ce raisonnement là qui rend
l'argument encore plus fort pour
sans dire imposer
d'un choix parce que le choix doit
demeurer toujours mais au moins
fortement suggérés
on a parlé de la covid l'exploitation
animale est au centre de ces prochaines
pandémies qu'on va vivre c'est sûr et
certain
pour toutes ces raisons là je trouve que
les évidences sont assez sont assez
énormes pour
pour un peu tronquer toutes les
contre-arguments j'ai l'impression
aussi aussi c'est par la simplicité puis
la chance qu'on a d'avoir accès à des
alternatives aussi simplement et puis
cette simplicité là si on l'utilise pas
ici en Amérique du Nord quand la seule
chose qu'on a besoin de faire c'est
changer d'aller à l'épicerie je sais pas
je sais pas qu'est-ce qu'on peut espérer
que les autres nations où est-ce qu'ils
ont pas accès à ça face mais pour toi
est-ce que le végétarisme est aussi
d'une certaine façon incohérente par
rapport au véganisme à mon avis oui à
mon avis c'est incohérent par contre
c'est déjà c'est déjà une avancement je
préfère beaucoup sauf qu'il fait
effectivement puis quelqu'un qui décide
d'être végétarien et non végétalien
c'est son cas il y a un incohérence sauf
que l'incohérence tant qu'on est
consciente on est cohérence puis tu
acceptes que ce soit dans que tu prennes
cette décision là je trouve que le
chouette
de mettre cette limite là sachant
avec laquelle je pouvais vivre dans un
sens
certains côtés je fais ma part il y a
quand même au niveau éthique un problème
mais
j'accepte de vivre avec moi
pour le moment parce que c'est avec quoi
je vis c'est je sais pas si le concept
de flexitariste
dit quelque chose fixitiste d'après ce
que j'ai compris c'est quand on est
quand même dans une démarche de devenir
végétarien c'est-à-dire que autant que
faire ce peu dans certaines
circonstances on
sacrifie volontairement la viande puis
dans d'autres contextes quand on a pas
le choix
on a toujours le choix mais c'est ça
exactement c'est que je te dirais que je
me considère en ce moment dans cette
démarche flexitariste dans le but
explicite de ensuite transitionner vers
le végétarisme à temps complet puis
ensuite en bout de ligne de devenir
végan le que je ne le suis pas en ce
moment je t'avoue que ça commence
vraiment à me
hanter
quotidiennement je sais toujours pas
quoi faire quand je regarde mon mon
enfant moi je sais pas quoi ça me trompe
je sais pas quoi penser de ça
tu vois moi c'est l'équation c'est ce
que j'ai pas dans mon équation
morale là devant mon enfant manger de la
viande
ici la question de est-ce qu'on doit
c'est parce que admettons maintenant que
je fais un parallèle avec justement
donner une partie de ces richesses
au plus des milices moi mettons à part à
mes impôts je le fais pas je veux dire
je donne pas une partie de
mais je pourrais décider de vivre
mettons au vraiment plus minimalement
puis je souvenais à mes besoins
de primaires
puis ça serait moralement supérieur
comme ça serait moralement supérieur
normalement que je serai Vigan mais que
ces deux choses que je fais pas sachant
que je pourrais faire mieux
amener
après ça c'est un jeu de calculer la
balance tu sais mais parce que l'impact
mettons sur ta qualité de vie de tout
donner le supérieur que ton appart ta
bouffe mettons à quelqu'un d'autre et
vraiment plus grand que prendre du lait
d'avoine
ça fait 5 ans que je le suis je le
remarque plus si je j'y pense plus
jamais ça m'arrive jamais chez nous j'ai
tout ce qu'il faut pour cuisiner
qu'est-ce qu'il doit qu'est-ce que je
prends je passe plus jamais dans l'aller
la viande j'ai j'ai pas pu au quotidien
c'est pas le sentiment de sacrifice je
sacrifie rien parce que j'y pense pas
j'ai aucun sacrifice tandis que ce qu'il
fallait qu'à chaque mois je vois une
partie de mon chèque partir de faire
tout ce qui est en surplus je le donne
mais je ferai comme ça mais si on le
voyait pas tu sais on parlait plutôt
d'un sujet à l'autre le métier sans le
voyait pas passer
de le sortir mais juste si l'argent
était mieux réparti et puis il t'a
jamais passé dans mon campement si par
exemple il y avait un mécanisme dans la
taxe dans notre feuille déclaration
d'impôts il y avait une question aussi
est-ce que vous acceptez de donner 10%
de votre revenu à des organismes
caritatifs à partir de votre pays brut
pas de problème il y a beaucoup de monde
peut-être qu'ils feraient c'est ça parce
que vous suivez jamais passé
on avait tout un niveau de vie un petit
peu parce que c'est dur de diminuer
quelque chose
une fois que tu as atteint un certain
niveau de vie c'est dur d'enlever
quelque chose à quelqu'un puis les
mettons je demande
confort puis là convaincre tout le monde
comme partager un bout de sa tarte c'est
offe mais si on l'avait jamais eu cette
boîte de tartelux j'étais juste toujours
été mieux réparti on aurait pas le
sentiment de faire un sacrifice je
comprends ce que tu veux dire je sais
pas si ça peut aider puis encore une
fois là justement je voulais quand même
confesser quand je parlais de
faybellisme je suis la preuve incarnée
de ce familisme par rapport au véganisme
on est tous on est tous mais je pense
qu'il faut de la intellectuelle à tous
les niveaux puis aussi reconnaître ses
propres fautes ou ses propres
incohérences mais par rapport à Peter
quand j'avais lu Peter Singer par
rapport à le problème de la pauvreté
dans le monde je suis allée sur son site
web et comme on dit un bon français à
l'époque c'était comme ça qu'on
fonctionnait on avait un tableau de
revenus puis suggérait un pourcentage
parce que un moment donné il s'est rendu
compte que sa convainquait personne
c'est que pour être conséquentiste pour
être pragmatique il a décidé de bon ok à
tel échelle salariale quel pourcentage
et c'était beaucoup plus facile et donc
j'ai je l'ai fait et à cette époque là
mais j'avoue que j'ai pas renouvelé
depuis alors je sais pas où est-ce que
j'en suis mais donc alors c'était des
prélèvements mensuels pour un moment
donné c'est un Médecin sans Frontières
UNICEF au commissariat des réfugiés
Croix-Rouges s'entraident et peut-être
autre chose mais c'était quand même 5
organismes caritatifs
déduction automatique mensuelle puis
c'est vrai que on voit pas passer
et puis donc je pense plus exactement
comme tu penses bien aller de viande
alors ça je peux toujours faire mieux et
puis il faut que je fasse mieux mais ça
c'est quelque chose que j'ai acquis
depuis quand même pas mal longtemps
maintenant pour ce qui est du véganisme
écoute
c'est peut-être aussi presque
psychologiquement
pervers de ma part de voir
ce que j'ai dit dans le courriel que je
t'ai envoyé sachant que il y avait parce
que peut-être que c'est
j'ai peut-être que justement j'avais
besoin d'être confronté encore pour me
dire que là il faut que j'y aille il
gagne plus vraiment intéressant mais je
te dirai que puis je voudrais quand même
que ça résonne avec toutes les personnes
qui sont dans cette démarche
vraiment quand un enfant qui veut pas
être Vigan qu'est-ce que tu fais si je
trouve ça compliqué parce que en même
temps c'est ma faute
puis en même temps je veux pas le forcer
c'est ça décision moi j'ai des parents
dans mon entourage qui ont qui sont
véganes qui ont élevé leur enfant vegan
puis il se pose pas de questions pour
toujours piler l'inverse des parents
vegan qui ont laissé le choix à leur
enfant tout le temps puis même des
parents ma sœur elle a laissé le choix à
ses quatre enfants d'être vegan ou non
parce qu'elle est végétale
presque presque puis les enfants ont
pris des des directions différentes le
Tuy il y en a qui mais avant d'avoir
l'âge d'apprendre une décision parce que
à deux ans tu prends pas à un an tu as
pas grand décision
donc est-ce qu'il y a des enfants qui
ont décidé de ne pas être viganes
à chaque fois qui a fait mettons au
dessus des affaires que des morphones
tout le temps les muffins
pour leur décision puis après ça
inversement mais mes amis qui ont élevé
leur enfant vegan qu'un enfant va être
en âge de d'aller manger chez des amis
il va être en âge de prendre sa propre
décision aussi de ce que tu veux manger
la viande chez tes amis ou non
la décision vient de l'inverse c'est
juste que peut-être que tu le starter
d'un côté où est-ce qu'il faut devoir
prendre la décision plus tard
je pense que ça sent bien bientôt
les plus jeunes le titre me comptait tu
étais déjà parlé de gagner dans une
classe il me semble tu m'avais dit puis
que
m'avait compté les questions qui est
végé ou Vigan ici c'est une bonne
proportion de la classe faut que j'ai
l'impression que c'est de plus en plus
comme un
maintenant que l'information est là
maintenant que les options sont là ça
prend de plus en plus de place
je peux abuser est-ce que j'ai le temps
d'une dernière question
5h37 à moins que vas-y
en fait on n'a pas parlé mais tu es
mentionner l'idée de la guerre juste oui
puis sans qu'on repartent trop longtemps
lorsque j'ai vraiment pas besoin
[Musique]
dans les contextes je veux dire
présent des dégâts dans le monde une
crainte moi chaque fois que je vois ce
mettons l'invasion de la Russie en
Ukraine
c'est comme si ça
ça c'est une absurdité le sait que un
humain décide je vais envoyer d'autres
humains tirer sur d'autres humains puis
que tout ça soit comme sous les yeux de
tout le monde dans le monde puis que
c'est comme on est pas trop d'accord
mais on peut pas faire grand-chose puis
que tout ça se passe puis que pour moi
c'est comme c'est un non sens le titre
il y a des des crimes de guerre des
crimes contre l'humanités qui sont faits
puis
rapport faire des sanctions c'est comme
puis justement philosophiquement c'est
c'est quoi notre devoir puis qu'est-ce
qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on fait est-ce que tu
es ce qu'on devrait envoyer un commando
exterminer Poutine boom c'est fini
par exemple
puis que personne qui se dit que c'était
des gens qui disent que c'est moral mais
il y a c'est pas ça pas fait le scandale
non plus donc c'est c'est je pleure
votre conversation est tellement
stimulante que ça spine dans toutes les
directions juste revenir sur le végan
je voulais juste spécifier quand même
que
ok c'est que je pense quand même le
centre de recherche en éthique dont je
suis plus directrice et ma collègue et
Vigan et je pense pas que c'est la
trahir parce que en fait notre politique
alimentaire public c'est qu'à chaque
fois qu'on finance euh des repas donc à
nous inviter etc ou au nom de notre
centre c'est absolument vegan alors ça
c'est quelque chose dans que je soutiens
et qui va exactement dans le sens la
démarche que
c'est ce que que j'aimerais tout
simplement que ça aille plus vite dans
ma vie et que je comprends que c'est
bizarre que ça soit pas encore déjà
arrivé c'était quoi l'autre chose que je
voulais dire par rapport à ça c'était ah
oui mais tu sais par rapport au
véganisme
sachant que par exemple il y a des
médicaments qui ont été faits
à cause du sacrifice des animaux dans
l'expérimentation
qu'est-ce que c'est comment comment en
tant que viking
je pense que on revient à la question de
ce que ça peut être évité puis si la
réponse est ça peut pas être évité pour
la survie de notre espèce puis je veux
dire dans
la notion du spécisme c'est vrai que de
pas mettre aucune espèce de
au-dessus des autres c'est un
capital dans la réflexion je crois quand
même que l'objectif de tous les espèces
c'est la survie de son espèce puis je
pense que dans cette optique là si ça
peut pas être évité puis c'est pour la
survie de l'espèce ce serait l'argument
que j'aurais à répondre puis les choses
qui ont été faites sur les animaux qui
maintenant peuvent être faites plus sur
les animaux mais les faut arrêter
absolument ces tests là on peut on peut
être
heureux d'avoir eu les les
aboutissements que ces études-là ont
créé on est on est great force on est
reconnaissant
si on peut l'éviter on l'évite
des choses qu'on peut pas éviter et qui
sont nécessaires à la survie de notre
espèce c'est ce que je répondrais
parce que c'est une question mercantile
que ça va plus vite c'est plus facile
sur des animaux faut le tester arrête la
question c'est plus à l'inverse quand
c'est jusqu'à présent ça ne peut pas
éviter qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on
fait c'est quoi la position
philosophique par rapport à ça alors là
il y a survie de notre espèce
pique que tu es capable d'assumer une
situation
toutes les espèces sont programmées pour
la survie de respect nous on est capable
de réfléchir possiblement qu'on qu'on
l'a su réfléchisse
pour revenir à ta question donc la
théorie de la guerre juge on est
peut-être maintenant perdu du début avec
la discrétion mais la théorie de la
guerre juste dans le domaine de
l'éthique des relations internationales
c'est très intéressant parce que ça a
presque comme coup
comment dire il y a eu la question de la
fin avec Peter Singer il y a eu la
question de la paix perpétuelle avec
Emmanuel Kant tout ça ce sont des idées
dans l'histoire des idées qui ont été
mobilisés euh il y a eu la question des
réalistes c'est-à-dire est-ce que pour
comprendre le comportement des états sur
la scène internationale on devrait les
concevoir simplement comme des agents
qui poursuivent leur propre intérêt donc
ça c'est une posture philosophique je
suis dans certains points puis il y a il
y a eu la théorie de la guerre juste à
peu près dans les années 70 un
philosophe qui s'appelle maiko azur qui
a décidé de ré-appliquer à travers
l'ouvrage incroyable d'ailleurs pour
tous ceux et celles qui adorent
l'histoire notamment l'histoire des
conflits armés c'est un livre à lire
parce que c'est très bien écrit en plus
et donc just an just Wars et là il va
réhabiliter une tradition qui est quand
même assez vieille qui remonte presque
au Moyen-Âge avec Thomas d'Aquin
Augustin pourquoi parce que c'était des
penseurs du judo christianisme qui
devaient se qui devait penser la chose
suivante
on est on anticipe l'invasion des
Barbares
qui s'enviennent ou les guerres alors au
nom de la sauvegarde du christianisme
comment peut-on violer un des principes
fondamentaux de comment dire de du
christianisme qui est caractère sacré de
la vie des innocents donc ils ont
mobilisé l'idée de cause juste pour
justifier le recours aux armes et
ensuite donc un autre saut dans
l'histoire on a des juristes grossistes
qui fait peur va-t-elle Victoria au 16e
17e siècle qui vont mais là on est dans
un autre contexte aussi l'expansion
commerciale c'est la traite des esclaves
c'est la navigation c'est le
colonialisme c'est la navigation sur les
eaux internationales etc et là on est en
train de réfléchir sur la codification
du droit à la guerre c'est pas
nécessairement parce qu'on est des
apologues de la gare mais parce qu'on
pense que la guerre est ineffable et au
moins on va essayer de réglementer dans
le droit international moderne qui n'est
autour du 16e 17e siècle ce qu'on a le
droit de faire en temps de guerre ou pas
ou dans quel contexte on peut faire une
déclaration de guerre etc et donc ça
c'était la tradition de la guerreuse qui
est tombée un peu en 18 Sud il y a eu
plutôt donc au 19e siècle des gens qui
ont classe vite puis là on était
vraiment dans des postures réalistes ou
la guerre et comment dire le dernier
recours quand tous les autres moyens ont
échoué et donc la guerre fait partie de
la vie politique entre les États puis là
vient la garde du Vietnam aux États-Unis
puis on est dans une époque hippie puis
on commence à remettre des choses en
cause mais justement la philosophie
politique appliquait appliquée comment
ça à avoir son essor et donc ma
covoiture s' à la théorie de la
guercheuse puis se demande est-ce que
l'acteur françois-américaine au Vietnam
est juste ou pas juste et pour lui elle
n'est pas juste et donc il s'intéresse à
cette tradition qui va l'appliquer c'est
une tradition qui est qui a connu qui
connaît présentement beaucoup beaucoup
de succès dans le domaine de l'éthique
des relations internationales mais qui
connaît aussi des critiques mais juste
pour rendre une version charitable de la
tradition de la guerre juste peu importe
les critiques qui sont aussi très
légitimes alors il y a des gens qui vont
par exemple dire puis Mako Ossus on
était quelqu'un qui disait dans
l'histoire de tous les conflits en
relation internationale il y a toujours
eu un bar qui a eu raison plus que
l'autre donc pour lui l'idée de cause
juste c'est la route et l'idée c'est de
faire de pouvoir rendre compte sur un
tribunal public de la raison
internationale donc par exemple
l'équivalent du Conseil de sécurité
le
motif de notre de notre cause juste et
de faire ce plaidoyer un peu comme je
sais pas si vous en souvenez mais à
l'époque où
avec ses perpoint était allé au Conseil
de sécurité pour dire que il y avait des
armes de destruction massive en Irak et
allons-y on y va au nom de la légitime
défense etc enfin bref c'était beaucoup
de returer peut-être mais l'idée c'est
que il y a comme une sorte de statut à
l'échelle internationale qu'il faut
avoir une cour juste qu'on peut défendre
ou au sein de la communauté auunisienne
pour aller en gare ou pas alors la
Russie je voulais pas rentrer
nécessairement dans des exemples
concrets mais juste comme ça la Russie
prétend que donc je sais pas moi que
l'OTAN a toujours brisé ses promesses de
ne pas faire d'expansion alors que tous
les signes indiquent depuis la fin de la
guerre froide que le temps en train de
l'expansion au bord de la Russie puis il
a la Russie invoque donc une certaine
vision de la grande réussite etc puis
120 envahir Ukraine
pour ces raisons là donc essaie
d'invoquer une cause qui convient ou pas
peu importe il faut quand même faire la
démonstration de ça et l'Ukraine
évidemment va donc invoquer le droit à
sa souveraineté politique à son
intégrité territoriale etc et en plus
l'Ukraine a jusqu'à un certain point
comment dire le
à son avantage l'idée que le Conseil de
sécurité la charte tunisienne permet le
recours aux armes seulement légitime
défense quand on a subi une attaque ce
qui était clairement le cas donc pour ce
qui est duplidate l'Ukraine il y a pas
vraiment de controverse à part ceux et
celles qui vont dire que la Russie est
dans son droit tout ça pour dire que
donc on comprend comment les outils
théoriques de la théorie de la guerre
juste se mettre en place et c'est très
intéressant aussi de constater que la
théorie de la guerre juste c'est pas
juste le droit à la guerre c'est aussi
ce qu'on a le droit de faire ou
exactement ce qu'on appelle le you sin
Bello qui était vraiment
[Musique]
c'est vraiment pas tellement plus
développé que ça alors ils ont commencé
à la Croix-Rouge internationale est née
de ça la Convention de Genève c'est
l'idée que un soldat quand il est en
poste quand il n'est pas son posture de
combattant il recouvre tous ses droits
et c'est pour ça que par exemple la
prison de Guantanamo
est violent toutes les conventions de
Genève parce que etc puis la prohibition
de la torture etc ce qu'il y a des
choses qu'on a pas le droit de faire en
temps de guerre maintenant on a plus le
droit de brûler on a palme des villages
de Vietnamiens sous prétexte que il y a
des vietnams qui sont cachés par là
c'est ça les principes c'est que c'est
vraiment très intéressant le terrorisme
est le plus souvent condamné parce que
c'est une violation fondamentale
premièrement du droit d'avoir une
déclaration
et deuxièmement le limiter des
non-combattants c'est que la taxe
surprise sans prendre à des innocents et
rien de plus ville que ça par rapport à
cette théorie puis là par rapport à
des cas Siri
Ukraine il a la transposition de la
théorie de la guerre juste sur des
tierces parties
est-ce que la théorie de la guercheuse
peut justifier l'intervention militaire
pour cause humanitaire alors Koffi
Hanane au lendemain du génocide de
Rwanda avait demandé à la communauté
anusienne d'y réfléchir et puis il y a
des mandatiers en fait des gens que
Michael yourself en fait des Canadiens
aussi mais il y avait pas mal de
Canadiens
pour réfléchir sur qu'est-ce qu'on
qu'est-ce qu'on pense de l'intervention
internationale pourquoi il se manita il
a souveraineté des États et ça donne
lieu à de responsabilités tu peut-être
qui est un document célèbre la
responsabilité de protéger qui consiste
essentiellement à dire à ouvrir la porte
à la possibilité d'intervenir
militairement au nom de cause
humanitaire
mais là on en est là c'est sûr que
l'inertie et l'inaction pendant le
génocide du Rwanda a lever le coeur de
tout le monde puis on sait le général va
mieux
mais le problème aussi c'est que quand
les Américains sont en train en Irak
c'était aussi au nom de nouvel ordre
mondial au nom de la démocratie libérale
c'est que on va donner un coup de
possibilités à tous les États qui ne
sont pas encore démocratiques
mais là évidemment on a peur que ça
glisse faire des formes d'impérialisme
en plus militarisé est-ce qu'on doit
intervenir au nom des femmes au nom des
droits des femmes dans
[Musique]
un Afghanistan en tout cas un moment
donné il y avait eu ce débat là puis on
avait dit ouais il faut y aller pour le
droit des femmes contre les talibans
puis évidemment que évidemment qu'il
faut se soucier de droit des femmes mais
l'ennui c'est que quand ils ont été très
vite assortir et là tout à coup qu'en
est-il des droits des femmes c'est que
on a peur d'un discours de deux poids de
mesure on a peur de tout ça c'est que ça
reste encore ça reste encore évidemment
des questions extrêmement compliquées
puis aussi le risque évidemment que ça
allume poudrière puis là c'est une
question philosophique mais c'est une
question quand même pragmatique avec
elle il faut il faut penser
énormément
de conversation vraiment merci beaucoup
merci d'avoir donné merci à tous les
deux c'était super